foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing immunopeptide
analysis sample preparation in needle
biopsy size tissue samples with AFA
technology
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by coveris to learn more visit
coveris.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you have during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Nicholas autret PhD senior business
development manager kovaris and Marco
tugmedi PhD principal scientist
diagnosis
Nicholas and Marco you may now begin
your presentation
thank you Megan hi everyone I'm Nicholas
from kuboris and I will introduce today
the concept of adaptive focused
Acoustics and this will be followed by
the main presentation by Marco about the
use of this technology to prepare sample
for immunomics
so I've been working at Cabarrus for
more than four years now and I've been
meeting a lot of customers into field of
program example bread and we've done
with those discussions that cover
researchers have a lot of challenges in
common and the first one is
reproducibility and this reproducibility
is caused by many steps that have
variations during the process
the Second
Challenge they have is how to automate
the sample process and how to get it
standardized and normalized and this
also has a lot of impacts about
reliability of the data and the general
runtime
we are also seeing more and more people
wanting to get more out of less and
trying to decrease the sample input and
this is also important because
um during the processing sample can be
allowed to for instance to surface
adsorption and last but not least and I
believe you will have a nice video at
the end of this talk throughput is also
becoming a key step and uh people want
to increase the speed increases
throughput and of course they want to
have an efficient process in place and
because sometimes deserves the best
treatment we wanted to to bring AFA to
you today and I'd like to say that we
are really specializing pre-analytical
sample prep instrumentation we have a
main technology named AFA or adaptive
focused Acoustics and we also have a way
to prepare more complex or more
important samples but I will focus today
on adaptive focused Acoustics which key
differentiators are first the ability to
really focus the energies that is
delivered to sample and also ensure a
Tamil control so that the sample
Integrity is preserved during the
process it's a non-contact approach and
it's available in another format
so that it can basically work from one
cell up to milligrams or even grams of
tissue
as I said the first objective of
reproducibility of health insurance is
reproducibility and one key advantage of
adaptive focused statistics is that it
really process the heart of the sample
without any damage to the sample and
this is because creating cavitation
through the syndication process
generates heat and we have a way to
instantaneously dissipate that heat so
that the sample remains at the same
temperature during the process and
unlike other Technologies based also on
syndication like props indication or
what about syndication will really work
in a concentrated zone of one to three
millimeter
and as a consequence you will create
heat to the sample that is creating that
variability between samples also to my
knowledge we are the only technology
able to process at the same time one two
three four samples and as such was the
only technology able to guarantee this
parallel and consistent treatment
between samples
one of the first
workflows that was designed with covaris
was based on the work by Evan kaisfield
with the sp3 approach sp3 stands for
single pod solid phase sample
preparation and in a paper released
early 2020
Miller described an auto sp3 approach
which allows to do a single pot
treatment of samples from the dispensing
into our plates down to the mass back
injection as you can see here on the
slide you can dispense the sample in our
plate process in the covaris where you
can do different steps like of course
lysis DNA shearing in some cases when
working with ffp you can even remove
paraffin without any solvent and after
that you can go into this sp3 process
where you bind protein to the beads and
you ensure with Washings that remove any
contaminant whether it comes from the
buffer or the perfume itself and after
that you can do trypsin digestion and
directly inject if you like or you can
also have an additional cleanup if
needed
we've worked with a lot of lab in the
past years and we've reached now more
than 200 Publications about sample prep
and these also allowed us to release
different application nodes you will be
able to find the links in the next slide
and we have been also able to work with
some customers to release new products
like this 384 well played that I
mentioned before
we developed with customers new
applications I mentioned this lysis and
paraffin removal and with Jessica
Chapman working at msk in New York we
also developed ways to process digestion
under three hours with adaptive focused
Acoustics and there is a video available
on our website if you want to learn more
we also worked with a group of genevonek
at celestinai in Los Angeles with lower
inputs to elicit the role of drug
perturbation in different cell cultures
and there is also a video available for
this
we worked with single cells you will
learn today about immunopept genomics
and we also worked on co-extraction
workflows and we have more and more
requests about SQL extraction for
instance of RNA and proteins but also we
have requests to work with buffers that
do not need to be removed like ammonium
bicarbonate and as such we are working
on new non-sds based workflows so that
customer can even reduce the number of
steps during the workflow
we have a lot of documentation available
on our website and many of these
documentation has been revised recently
so you really have uh the up-to-date
information about the possibility
offered by adaptive Focus acoustics
and because of this hard work we really
believe that your samples deserves the
best treatment and that this best
treatment discoveries acoustics
now it's time to me to thank you for
your attention and hand over to Marco
thanks a lot a lot Nicholas uh I'm
actually very excited to have the
opportunity to talk to you about how we
actually apply IFA technology to
optimize and improve our
immunopeptidomics pipeline
the immune system is a layer defense
system which increasing specificity
the first layer of defense is the innate
immunity which has physical components
such as as the skin chemical and
cellular components and these Target
pathogens or would like pathogens in a
non-specific manner
if this is not enough and the pathogen
manages to develop and invade The Host
the Adaptive immune system kicks in and
generates our antigen specific cellular
response that very efficiently clears
the pathogen
but how is this antigen specificity
ensured
it is ensured through the self
non-self-recognition made by T cells and
this happens molecularly at the level of
the T Cell receptor here depicted in
green
that recognizes our antigen or MHC MHC
Associated peptide here represented in
blue or also known as immunopeptide that
it's bound by MHC molecule
which in humans
it's called HLA so MHC is the term for
vertebrates hlaids for humans and this
interestingly comes from the most
polymorphic Gene cluster in the human
genome it's hypomorphic we have more
than 17 000 allelic forms reported to
date and what it's fascinating about
this is that each of these forms Alters
the structure and the specificity of
this MHC molecule so we see here The
Binding left of our MHC class 1 molecule
more about that later and we see that
these binding pocket is very tight and
we can imagine that different amino
acids on the MHC level here will have an
effect on which peptide is
preferentially bound in this pocket and
so different allotypes so different
allelic form of HLA molecules we've
changed the spectrum of peptides that
are presented by the by cells through
the immune system
an important thing is that
if a peptide binds
HLN molecule it does not mean you will
have an immune response because this is
then the T Cell receptor recognizing it
in a immune activating environment that
will lead to immune response
and importantly we have two classes
so plus one is presented by all nucleate
cells and cells that don't express any
class one are targeted for killing
it presents its antigens to cytotoxic T
cells
and each cell in our body can present to
up to six different allotype of HLA
class 1 molecules
this already shows the variability and
large spectrum of peptides that can be
bound and presented by HLA molecules
and it plays a very important role in
the cell mediated response because it
presents the antigen to cytotopic T
cells that then decide whether or not to
kill the cell
and the peptide growth of this molecule
it's very defined so that peptides bound
to this class 1 HLA are usually
non-amino acid in length with little
variability there
last two on the other hand it's
presented only on immune cells
this makes
um the presentation of the antigen 2T
helper cells which then orchestrate a
immune response
each single cell can present up to 16
different allotypes of Class 2 HLA
molecules
and it plays a very important role in
the humeral response so activation of B
cells and antibody production
binding Groove is actually open on the
side so it looks more kind of a hot dog
and so the length of these peptides is
much more viable
so the immunobeptides are the key player
of the antigen specific immune response
but what are the application fees where
immunopectics could help
actually any disease susceptibility
study because you want to understand is
there
or understand what happens there
it plays an important role in autoimmune
diseases as well as grout versus host
diseases and here of particular interest
is the prediction or
looking at what if a gene therapy will
then generate immunopeptide and antigens
to which we will then have a immune
response so it's very important to
understand how gene therapy affects the
immune system
and then of course a very hot topic is
the person's cancer immunotherapies here
we have to distinguish between new
epitops so these are antigens that come
from tumor specific mutations so they
will be not found on healthy samples or
tumor Associated antigens where these
can be found in the healthy samples or
healthy tissue but are much higher in
intensity so much more presented on
tumor on tumor
and also it can be very helpful in
helping designing treatment method
might be vaccines or cell based
Therapies
so overall I think the key of the
specific immune response understanding
them has the potential to lock on unlock
this powerful machine that will
depending on whether you want more or
less immune responses
however there are many challenges link
to it and that's why immunopeptideomic
has been a growing field but played with
some high challenges the first one is it
usually requires very large sample input
amounts in the range of grams
since they bind to a specific molecule
it's known that this pector actually
Limited in the physical chemical
variability they present because they
have to bind to this protein first
also they tend to poorly ionize because
they don't have the classic basic amino
acids that leads to good ionization as
well as a nice y ion fragment Series so
the fragmentation pattern of these
peptides is non-conventional
which results in information for MS2
Spectra making it much harder to
identify
peptides and being confident in their
identification and finally something
that until a couple of years ago was
kind of daunting and impossible is the
fact that the search space that we
generate there is humongous because you
don't have any specificity so you have
to look for any possible peptide in your
database
that's why we came up with a solution
that we call the true discovery
immunopeptide
here we start with either cells or
tissues an important step is to Native
lysis and this is where we use adaptive
Focus Acoustics because it's very
important that the cells are lies and we
generate this Emulsion in under native
conditions because the next step is a
magnetic immunoprecipitation here we use
antibodies that recognize specific
classes so we'll say of HLA molecules
for example plus one tentai class 1 HLA
molecules
and pull them down so it's important and
the samples are
native and the proteins maintain the
conformation they they have in cells
here we use magnetic beads so that we
can really have a highly automated
pipeline we can use 96 Wells both
fertilizes as well as then Forte
monoprecipitation
we then separate
the peptides from dately molecules which
we then shoot on
through our LCM SMS
here we use state of the arc technology
for example we use same iron Mobility
based separation in order to generate a
extra layer of separation and increasing
our
confidence in our
identifications we are co-inventors of
Dia data independent acquisition and
this is also why we then invested here
on optimizing this Dia method
specifically for immunofeconomics as
well as DDA method that is data
dependent acquisition and we found both
optimized methods work really well uh
but DIA has a sensitivity in the range
of 50 to 100 more so we see more
peptides with Dia but this is also
expected
and as the final step we analyze our
data with in-house software so we have
spectrumine and spectronaut which which
a little bit specifically because as we
discussed earlier these samples and this
Spectra that we get are quite peculiar
and you need some tweaks to be sure that
you analyze things correct
we did quite some extensive optimization
for this enrichment uh does not have any
digestion and the you have the
possibility of generating two
measurements from one sample because you
can first pull down plus one HLA and
then take the same lysate and pull down
plus Loop so generally effectively
generating two samples from one sample
and being such a complicated pipeline we
spent a lot of time optimizing it so we
did more than 33 rounds of optimization
by now and we measured more than
thousand samples so we are really
confident about our Pipeline and how it
performs however every time you have a
new pipeline you first have to look is
it actually generating the kind of data
that I would like for this we processed
triplicate JY cell so we use 20 million
cells of these JY cells these are B
cells so they express both plus one and
Class 2 HLA molecules
we process them in triplicate and what
we can look at is which the number of
peptides that are found across all three
samples and we found more than 10 000
peptides so this is a really large
number of peptides and a very high
reproducibility we then as a second step
we pull down also Class 2 and also here
to
reproducibility is really good I'll have
it a bit lower than four class one which
makes sense because this is a subsequent
step so every step you do in
Biochemistry you will increase your
noise
and all that you can do in order to
check for the quality is looking at the
peptide length distribution because as I
said especially for class 1 we expect
peptides to be mostly non-amino acid in
length and some are a bit shorter a bit
longer but a very sharp Peak on 9 amino
acid in length so if we plot the
fraction on the y-axis of peptides at a
different peptide lengths we find again
this is the JY data set a very nice Peak
at Nightmares showing that we are
confidently in reaching for these
peptides here
we can do the same plot for Class 2 and
find again a
the picture we would expect so uh wider
this decision in this case
a nice thing if you use a cell line that
you know a lot of and there is sure
about is that you can look deeper into
the data and checking their profit a
possibility for immunopeptideomics
especially for class one
is looking at the anchor positions so as
discussed differently allotypes bind
preferentially specific peptides
and for class 1 since the binding cleft
is so well defined
very conserved for example position one
and position eight are known to be quite
strictly controlled
so what you can do is example for the
data set from before with the
triplicates we can look at the fraction
of peptides that have each specific
amino acid at position number one
and then here I plot the three so first
thing is higher producibility the three
bars of different colors are very
similar the second thing we notice is
the in position one we mostly find
prolines for kind of 50 of the cases we
also find a lot of leucins and
isolutions
so this is the picture so we have a very
strong binding preference what we can do
is go and look in the literature for
this cell line for which we know the
yellow type what are the kind of
peptides that are predicted to buy
and
this very much agrees with what we see
again showing that we generate very nice
quality data
we repeated the same for position number
eight and again uh the enrichment that
was expected from the literature so
position a doesn't have a ProLine as
common amino acid but has loose in there
another thing and something that is very
widespread is the use of prediction
algorithms so you can feed peptide
sequences known allotypes and ask the
algorithm to predict how strongly it
will bind to this halotypes we run this
data through uh one such algorithm and
we found that about 80 percent of our
peptides are predicted as strong binders
so to summarize
the reproducibility of the data is
really high we find the peptide length
distribution expected and in the case we
have download titanation this was the
case of dry cells and this works also
better for class one we can check for
the anchor position and predicted
binding affinity and come to the
conclusion that the quality data is
comparable to published data sets in all
metrics which is a lot of confidence
about our pipeline
we next ask how many cells are actually
needed for such a pipeline because as I
told you internal literature carries a
lot about how many cells you need but
since we kind of developed this entire
pipeline from scratch we really asked
how sensitive are we for this we took
again JY cells and we generated a cell
ramp from 0.1 to 50 million cells
and then the question is and what is
plotted on the y-axis how many
immunopeptides can we see with these
different amounts of cells
what we found that we are very sensitive
already with 5 million cells we can see
more than 7000 peptides and we find a
plateau at 20 billion cells so we have
this very nice effect of kind of
saturation of C we then repeated Class 2
as a follow-up and found a very very
similar picture but with higher number
this is because Class 2 is known to be
more heterogeneous
next we asked how much Frozen tissue is
actually needed because this is really
the burning question
and here we run from 2.5 to 135
milligram for class 1 we found we are
really really really sensitive so this
was healthy lung tissue already with 10
milligram we reach the plateau more than
10 000 peptides
and uh
then we perform the same for class two
and here we were quite surprised because
as you can see we increased the number
of peptides we see with increasing
tissue input and this actually makes
sense if we think about the biology
autoterogeneity of the immune cells you
will have in tissue as well as the
different allotypes and so on and so
forth so this is actually expected
we then partnered with the living in
order to look for new antigen so what we
did here is applied our classical
pipeline but complemented it with
individmate abilities in whole
sequencing variant calling and
translated faster so generating expected
mutations that we could then query in
Spectrum iron and spectronaut to look
for new antigens so new antigens as a
refresher is antigen so immunobepeptides
that present a mutation that is unique
to the tumor and is not in healthy
samples
the first thing when you generate a data
set it's always looking at the Quality
so we looked at the vector length
distribution here in Gray for class 1
and even for class two again very nice
sharp picker Niners for HLA class one
and a wider one for uh class two
so what we did is apply this pipeline to
the colorectal to a colorectal cancer
cohort we had 20 samples
we process 15 milligrams of fresh frozen
sample perform both class 1 and class
two immuno epidemics
overall found
more than 100 000 immunopeptides and on
average average 9700 for class one and
sixteen thousand four plus two what we
then looked at is just the number of
peptides for both classes Plus One will
be then plotted in Gray plus two in red
across the different samples and what we
found was that while for class 1 the
variability is relatively relatively low
for class two the number of peptide you
can find in the sample varies a lot for
example in Sample three we had more than
25 000 and in Sample 18 uh just a couple
of hundreds of
peptides I immunopeptides identify and
then this again feeds into how cold or
hot the different samples were so how
many immune cells they had there or
but could we identify new antigens yes
we could for class one we found 16
neurontigens mapping to nine point
mutations so these are single amino acid
mutations and to see six frame shift
mutations for Class 2 we identify 29 new
antigens 19 point mutations and three
frame shifts and overall what we then
can look at is the number of new
antigens per number of samples so we
have the sample numbers on the x-axis
the number of neural antigens identified
on the y-axis and then I highlighted the
five sample that are MSI low so these
are samples that have a longitational
burden while the other 15 samples have a
high mutational burden so there you
would expect more neurons and then again
using this gray for class 1 and red for
Class 2 we can look at the number of new
antigens we find across these samples
and what I found very nice is that for
almost all MSI High cancer so 13 out of
15 we have at least one near antigen and
what was also striking it's that only 50
about 50 of these samples had neuro
antigens for both classes showing that
if you want to increase the likelihood
of finding new antigens performing both
class one and plus two monopeptidomics
makes a lot of sense
next we looked if
this number of new antigens actually
correlates with the mutational burden so
what we plotted is number of new
antigens on the y-axis versus the number
of genomic mutations on the x-axis and
what we found is that about 1 out of
thousand mutations on the genomic level
make its way all the way out and it's
presented by HLA molecules on the cell
surface
showing that it is quite rare events but
it's a considerable number
now I would like to showcase a very nice
example and these maps to elongation
Factor one alpha one this is a
elongation Factor as says and what's
interesting is that it's
known to be the outer antigen in 66
percent of patients with fatty syndrome
so this is our autoimmune disease and in
66 percent of these patients it's known
that a immunopeptides are antigen coming
from this protein is the one the immune
system recognizes
so we can look at the number of
immunopeptides that map to this protein
that we found across the different
samples so we have the number of
immunopeptides on the y-axis and the 20
samples on the x-axis and then again in
Gray we have plus one in red we have
plus two and what we found both are
overwhelming presentation by class 2. in
Sample one we found close to 40
different immunopeptides mapping to
elongation Factor one Alpha One
and in Sample 18 just a couple
overall
they mostly map to class 2.
and it seems to be a highly uh
recognized protein
but it's interesting is that in Sample
five we have our alanine to training
mutation so this is a point mutation in
one specific amino acid of the sequence
and then the question was can we
actually see this mutation on presenter
on the HLA molecules
and this was also more interesting
because we have 20 peptides that
actually mark this region so we have a
very good resolution of this region so
what we did next was plotting the
intensity of the peptides presented
across the samples for this about 20
peptides that map to this region and
then we color this peptide in in green
if they contain the wild type so the
alanine and in red if they contain the
train only so the mutated amino acid and
in Gray if they are just next to it but
don't contain any specific information
on the amino acid
and what we found was that on most of
the samples we have peptides mapping to
the wild type amino acid and this also
in Sample number five which is actually
heterogeneous heterozygous for uh this
specific mutation
but what is very exciting is that we
don't find one Neurontin but we find
five different peptides presented by HLA
class two molecules there
of being a Mass Spec Company and being
Mass Spec nerds we always especially
when we look for real things we really
want to look at the raw data and making
sure that this is true so what you can
do in spectronaut is for example looking
at the wild type to as a comparison
these we found in fine samples and what
you can do is look at the MS2 xic so
here you're looking at the Coalition of
the fragments generated from this
peptide and it looks very nice but you
can also look at the ms-1 isotope
envelope so here you are looking at the
distribution of different isotopes
present in nature and is expected to
generate a distribution at the level of
the peptide and also this one looks very
nice and also you can look at the MS2 so
at the fragmentation spectrum and what
we are looking here at is one of the
most beautiful fragmentation Spectra
I've ever seen so there is almost a
complete B why on Series in blue and one
y ion series and on the bottom you also
see that all of these fragments are
matched with very good accuracy
then what we can do is go into one
sample where we have the new antigen and
look at the same features
since alanine and trionine are very
similar
physically except the mass so they are
not active chemically
so much
what we would expect it's very similar
pattern but we increase in Mass
and indeed we find practically the exact
same picture the exact same
properties that at the massive range
that you would expect for this mutation
so for this amino acid change so we see
everything at 15 M over Z higher so this
corresponds to the 30 gram mole increase
in Mass for this mutation
so we have General generated a scalable
efficient class one in class 2
immunopeptidomics pipeline which
generates great quality data we find
class 1 and Class 2 to be complementary
in identifying your antigens at at least
in colorectal cancer and we find more
new antigens mapping to Cluster
overall we could find for almost all
cancer that had a high mutational burden
at least one new antigen and overall we
could identify uh more than 40 new
antigens and this in as little as 20
samples
for what else do we actually use Alpha
technology and why uh so to conclude I
would like to just give that you are
Glimpse about that so as Nicolas said
reproducibility is key the possibility
of having multiple machines that perform
the same
the fact that it's scalable we can work
with 96 well in the 96 will format
and it doesn't need toxic chemicals
and this is particularly interesting for
the ffpe sample processing what we had
beforehand was a very manual tedious and
very toxic process that took a very long
time and what we now have with Alpha it
can act we can actually process 96
examples
in six hours with only 30 million of
manual pipetting
also the sensitivity is really good
because we can use as little as five
square millimeters of tissue from a 10
micrometer thick slide to generate
enough data for our Pipelines
and what we get is not just any kind of
identification it's very very close or
even the same as we get for fresh frozen
so from one sample we can get
up up anything upwards from 9000 protein
group identifications with direct V8 so
not even with a library
and as Nicolas already said but we
actually have we have integrated our
kovaris into a larger liquid handling
platform so I asked you if you want to
see this to click on this video and you
will see how uh this liquid Handler goes
and pick up the plate brings it to the
kovaris puts it in then it takes it out
it dries it because it comes from a
water bath that ensures that
temperatures is correct throughout the
process and then brings it back to to
the liquid Handler and so like this we
can actually automate completely the
entire pipeline for ffp sample
processing from A to Z so you just put
in your samples and then you come back
back to next day you have your peptides
on a plate that you can put on a mass
pack and at this point I would like to
thank you for your attention and I'm
very much looking forward to your
questions
foreign
formative presentation if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for let's get started Mark
what looks like our first question is
for you today and that question is how
much optimization was needed on the
kovaris side for the immunopeptidonics
pipeline
so that's a great question uh so we find
the covarius device to be very powerful
it also has a lot of settings you can
use and I think it was about 10 rounds
of optimization in which we tested
different buffers and all different
settings you have on the covaris device
and we found them to be very helpful and
you have a lot of flexibility to
actually get the quality of the data at
the end that you actually want
great thank you and our next question
looks like it has a few parts to it so
the first part of that question is on
the biological side did you find
neopeptides derived from the reoccurrent
frame shift mutations in nsih CRC
okay can you repeat the question
especially the last part yeah of course
it says on the biological side did you
find neopeptides derived from
reoccurrent frame shift mutations in
msih CRC
yeah yes not so many uh but we did find
also our sample size with 20 samples and
five being a low mutational burden we
didn't have that kind of sample size to
really ask this kind of biological
questions it was more a kind of proof of
concept we can see in our epitopes uh
with good sensitivity and this would be
the next step to really go into the
biology looking at things that occur
multiple times but we had cases of
friendship mutations that we found on
multiple samples and were present in
multiple samples
great thank you and the next part of
that question is on the technical side
did you also try to use in
silicone-generated fragmentation
libraries to increase the number of
detectable neopitaides did you compare
AFA to the commonly used protocol
so we
so this is again a two-side question so
let me start from the bottom so to say
uh so we did not compare our pipeline to
a standard protocol this is just because
we developed a protocol so to say from
scratch and chose the best step along
the way uh however from the numbers I
think it's pretty clear that our
pipeline is better than the current
pipelines so I don't see uh
yeah that why we should then test that
as well and then regarding the first
part was about
um
can you refresh my memory
yes it says did you compare AFA to the
commonly used protocol
yes this is the part I just answered uh
um on the technical side did you also
try to use silicone-generated
fragmentation libraries
yeah that's that's a great question uh
we tried a lot of things we find the
classical way of generating libraries
being the best especially considering
FDR considerations and their very large
search space that you have because of
the mutations that you are introducing
great thank you our next question is did
you generate spectral libraries for the
HLA data if so how many fractions did
you use
yes so we did generate a library and in
this case it was 15 fractions that we
used
great our next question asks how do you
separate the peptides from the HLA
molecules
uh this you had multiple possibilities
what we do is uh using a classical
cleanup step and then you can choose
with your organic solvent you can then
decide what you are eluting there
great thank you our next question asked
does the amount of sample affect the
detection of Nano antigens and
immunopeptide Analysis or is it used to
release to mutation load
so if you use 15 Milli milligram I think
it doesn't matter
the mutational burden will be more
significant in affecting the results
while if you as this especially for
class one of course for class two if you
increase the amount of sample you
process you will see more peptides and
so you will also likely see more Neo
antigens so yes sample input is a bit
limiting I think less than with other
pipelines but this is one of the great
challenges of immunopeptideomics is
the the samples amount you have
awesome thank you Nicholas it looks like
our next question is for you will covers
be able to share these protocols
the short answer is no I think this is
appropriately to diagnosis so I've done
a lot of optimization
what I can say and Marco you will be of
course able to commit after that is that
we are of course always Keen to support
developments I think that the ffpe
workflow that was presented by Marco we
helped them optimize at least the first
steps and we can do that for any of our
customers but for that specific workflow
here I think that it would remain a
property of diagnosis Marco you want to
comment that that's correct no that's
that's everything yeah
thank you
um Marco are you only using orbitrap
instrumentation or have you also tried a
Tens tof
so we we have tried
we have tried uh We've not comment more
on that but it works really well it's
yeah
great our next question asks are other
fields what are other fields in which
you plan to use covaris
so we actually plan to to cover all our
pipelines especially now with
integration within the liquid angular we
want to do DNA sharing and it has a lot
of capabilities to really improve the
quality of the samples and
reproducibility of it so we are planning
to practically do all kind of licenses
with it
great thank you our next question for
you asks how easy was the implementation
in the robot
that that was challenging uh of course
every time you do this is a very large
it's as big as a room the entire robot
and we have a lot of third-party devices
so it took us about
maybe six months to get it to work so uh
it's not as easy uh but just because of
ultra dependencies you have and you have
to think exactly what you want to do and
how
great thank you and our next question
asks are you following up on the Neo
antigen targets
great question since it was a
collaboration we really want we're
focusing on the technical side while
leaving the biology so to say to our
collaborators uh I know they are uh
liking the result and thinking about how
to proceed there
yeah and it looks like we have one more
question for today and that is how
robust is the ffpe protocol
we we found it to be super robust we are
really happy especially with the low
input amount that we can use as well as
different formats so we found the most
challenging part was to put the kind of
wraps of ffp uh in the plate but cover
is actually also then offered to us this
uh bigger ependorf so to say or bigger
cubes where you could put them in and
that was much easier to then do that
step as well
um and we also find it to be super
reproducible even if you stay in the
slides if you're in these stay in the
slides and all of these things so it's
really really reproducible
great thank you both so much for
answering those questions for our
audience do you have any final comments
I can just step in here just to comment
on the last point from from Marco
because we are working on ffp with a lot
of customers and I think that this
flexibility between the blade format
when you work with lower inputs or with
the tube format when you want to to to
go for a much larger content is also a
great
strength of the kovaris approach and we
can of course help designing other
workflows Marco mentioned that uh
working with cells with tissues and
there are also other types of samples
that can be used with coveris technology
I would say outside of this mammalian
world but ffpe fresh tissue cells are
really our heart of application today so
don't hesitate to come back to us if you
have any question also about Marco you
mentioned having tested different
buffers and it's also something we can
help with whether you work with a
detergent with urea based buffer with
non-detergent alcohol detergent free
please ask us and we'll be able to help
here
okay great thank you again Nicholas and
Marco for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank labroots and our sponsor kovaris
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye